Dave we've been watching the show over
the last couple days you've referenced
this 5,000 migrants that can come in
illegally every day but they're saying
no well actually I am right and when we
had Brock open up his trusty iPhone and
multiply 5,000 times
365 days a year that is about 1.8
million illegals and yes they will be
allowed in here so unfortunately for
Lanford and Cinema and uh this Bloomberg
reporter yes you can now be fact checked
in real time on X which is exactly
what's happening so here's GRE price
who's an actual journalist he wrote this
with actual evidence from the bill
itself not only does this bill cautify
1.5 million illegal border crossings
into law but the Border emergency that
automatically gets implemented at 5,000
Crossings per day in a week can be
overturned by Joe Biden and in case 1.5
million illegals isn't enough it also
locks in Green Card giveaways through
2030 uh he continues great news for for
everyone coming onto our Southern border
if you cross it illegally get arrested
and mayorcas Stooges decide you entitled
to protection they will now be able to
give you an automatic employment
authorization thanks to Mitch McConnell
and James Langford so okay so this seems
to be the key part of this right
now we have all of the laws to stop the
illegal immigration the very issue that
they kept telling us for months and
months wasn't happening now they're
acknowledging it's happening and now
they are literally from Lankford on the
Republican side to Kirsten Cinema on the
independent side but all the Democrats
because the Democrats want more of this
illegal immigration they are all telling
us that this 5,000 illegal immigrants a
day thing is not real it is real it is I
mean we literally just showed you the
part of the text that is in the bill it
is real and I've been asking some other
people while I'm in town
here